mais beaucoup de gens sont venus faire
de la publicité pour le canada dans les
lycées sont venus nous vanter de
l'université donc ça donnait envie d'y
aller
et c'est plus sécurisant qu'en france
les baies cours sont meilleures les
amphithéâtres sont moins sont moins
remplies donc je me suis dit bon autant
aller au canada
c'est une nouvelle approche franchement
c'est les gens ici ils ont une ouverture
d'esprit vraiment développer je trouve
que c'est exceptionnel
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
est même venu on nous a parlé
les doyens et tous nos autres
t'expliquer tout ce qui avait un rapport
avec vaguement domaine on a visité les
locaux et super des gens sont très
agréables
c'est un choix de vie il a demandé
beaucoup d'investigations et j'ai dû me
battre pour arriver jusqu'ici
c'est une nouvelle expérience pour pour
moi et ça change beaucoup de la
martinique
si le système d'identité et donc nous on
fait mon propre emploi du temps avec mon
cours c'est vraiment bien on est enfin
shakur chante les classes qu'on côtoie
plus de personnes
pour l'instant ça va la température
ce sera un petit problème mais bon pour
l'instant n'était pas encore trop
froisser plus en hiver cas ça va se
corser
qu'est ce qu'on redoute le plus je
dirais le froid parce que les -30 degrés
en hiver ce sera vraiment difficile